your predecessor Boris Johnson launched
the whole leveling up project because he
said that he wanted to help specifically
deprive communities out of London the
South London the southeast because he
said that they were overheating now it
is just a fact in absolute terms London
the southeast got more than a lot parts
of the country you're concentrating on
per head funding that's a long-term
justification for spending Less on the
North that we've seen across many many
decades are we getting the kind of
leveling up that we were promised in the
2019 general election by Boris Johnson
and is the thing that's really changed
that you're worried about losing
Southern seats and one linked question
are you a hundred percent committed to
the current plans for hs2 so again it's
kind of version of the same same
question Sam but look we are completely
committed to leveling up across the
United Kingdom and we've already been
through a couple of ways of saying the
same thing if you look at how we're
spending this money it is
disproportionately benefiting people in
the Northeast the north west and that's
what that's great right and that is
great and part of what the problem prime
minister said is actually one of the
criterias in this fund it looks at the
previous investment an area has received
because part of what we're trying to do
here is say hang on there are some
places that seem not to get the
investment that others got and we want
to try and correct that where we can and
that's actually one of the criteria for
what we're doing today and we remain
committed to delivering it it's got I
mean we've talked about the polar
politics of it I think about half or
around half the funding that we announce
over the the course of today or both
funds has actually gone to places that
are not controlled by conservative MPS
or councils from memory it's around half
so I don't think anyone can say it's
being done on that basis there's a
completely objective transparent
criteria it's all online it talks about
the things I talked about with all of
you before we look at a project and say
can it be delivered who had the question
about how long it's going to take right
I really like to say hang on no point
doing stuff that can't work right can it
be delivered this project is it a good
fit for the local area and what's the
need of the local area is one of the
specific criterias and then because you
know we talked about I can't do
everything we talk about value for money
right like if we spend a pound here are
we going to get you know kind of two
pounds of value back from it if we spend
a pound here and we only get 50p that's
probably less good those are the types
of things that we look at this is
ultimately on spending all this money on
your behalf those are all the things
that you probably want me to look at to
make sure that we're putting it in the
right places so that's how we've gone
about it and I'm really confident that
it will make a a big difference